بالنسبه الى ناطق الالوسي فن النحت ليس
مجرد مهنه بل هو
حياته هو ويقول ناطق ان الفن جمال وسلام
ورقي وانه لا يجد للخلود منا الا في
الاثار القديمه ومن ضمنها المنحوتات لذلك
اختار هذا الفن مهما كان حجم المنحوته
يبدا ناطق برسمه بسيطه ومن ثم يبدا
بالبناء لمسه بسيطه ولكنها قد تاخذ بعد
ذلك وقتا
طويلا اما التقنيه فما زالت هي نفسها منذ
ان بدا الفنان بالنحت في صغره وافضل
مواضيعه هو الحصان فهو رمز للقوه وتراثه
العراقي الفن بالعراق هو عاش جزء من عائله
الالوسي اوجه في فتره حكم صدام حسين ولقد
راى صدام قيمه في الم حتات لان التماثيل
العملاقه غير قابله للتكسير كما انها تمنح
الانطباع بقوه القائد ناطق كان من بين
الفنانين الذي بنى تماثيل صدام مع السيف
وعلى الاحصنه ويقول ناطق انه كان من
المؤلم مشاهده الفن يتكسر ويهان حين هدم
تماثيل صدام حسين عند سقوط حكمه عام 2003
ويضيف انه لا يندم على عمله لدى صدام حسين
بل يفتخر به ويقول ان اعظم الفنانين
اشتغلوا للزعماء واما الان فهو يعمل على
النحت مستعملا مواد مختلفه في ابو ظبي
ولكنه قلق بعض الشيء فليس هناك من يريد
تماثيل كبيره الحجم ومع ذلك ف ناطق
الالوسي لا يستسلم